Hey, awesome job.
And now we can actually see
the translation of the words in our app.
So let's take a step back for a moment,
and reflect on all that we've learned.
So first, we covered how to use arrays.
And then we switched over to
using lists, remember lists?
They were great.
And then we learned about loops.
Then we had to learn about view
recycling, using the list view and
the ArrayAdapter.
But we ran into some limitations
with the ArrayAdapter, so
we created a custom ArrayAdapter to
display specifically word objects.
Now each of these skills can be used for
apps beyond your MeWalk app.
And I encourage you to take time and
reflect on how you can use these
skills in your future projects.
Now I'd like you to sit back and
reflect on different places you
can apply the skills that
you've learned in this lesson.
So we covered topics such as arrays,
lists, loops,
view recycling, ListView and
ArrayAdapters, and custom ArrayAdapters.
So boy, there are a lot of topics.
And after you reflected on it,
go ahead and
share your thoughts on
the discussion forms.
And check out what other
students have said, too.